I'm Phil bauscher the director of Life
Sciences and Healthcare here at posit
I'm going to help moderate the session
today we're going to be doing some q a
you'll see that popping up on the right
hand side we'll also be doing Q a
through slido we'll share that link
we'll also be doing questions coming in
from YouTube so lots of exciting uh
questions coming in and we'll tackle
those at the end of the session today
over the last 10 to 15 minutes
I'm very excited to bring to you today
the eighth installment of our life
sciences series previously we
highlighted BMS Merck GSK navarros
Johnson and Johnson and others you can
find these posit webinars linked below
um from my team and today we have an
exciting sequel to our July 2019 webinar
by rosh and genintech that highlighted
the role of R and Drug Discovery
research and development
and today we're going to highlight the
awesome work being done by Roche and
Genentech and shifting to an open source
Backbone in clinical trials this amazing
work is being led by James Black the
senior director of insights engineering
and data and statistical Sciences will
kick off the presentation today with
Karen Martin the r enablement lead and
statistical programmer we'll then pass
it over to Thomas needman code
collaboration lead and data scientists
as well as the technical lead for the
Admiral r package
will then end with ningling people on
product lead and product development and
data Sciences
Roshan Genentech is such an inspiration
from the Legacy with Robert gentleman to
the contribution and countless hours to
the open source drug development
Community a true load star in our space
working with other pharmas and
contributing to efforts such as Admiral
and the pharmac the mmrn package the FDA
pilot submissions bioconductor our core
our tables and countless other projects
for the community over 10 people
contributed workshops or talks at the RN
Pharma conference in November and you
can find those videos on the RN Pharma
YouTube page linked below
and it's with great honor and pleasure
to bring this session to the community
today and now I'll pass it over to Karen
to kick off the webinar
so
um
I'll explain to that let's wait a minute
okay great
um yeah so thanks so much Phil for that
intro it's um really great that uh our
efforts are being seen in the wider
Community
um so today
um yeah myself Thomas and ning are going
to talk about the uh next steps we're
making at rush
um uh the steps we're kind of been
making already and what's happening this
year
so I'm gonna start by just providing an
introduction as to uh what it is exactly
we're talking about in terms of Shifting
to an open source backbone
um and kind of why we've got to this
point why we've made the uh decision
right now to switch that
um then Thomas is gonna get into what
that looks like in terms of the platform
we're building to do our work on and the
tools um that we're going to use on that
platform uh then he's going to hand back
to me and I'm going to talk about how
we're getting our talent base ready to
switch from one language to another and
also how we're kind of trying to move to
a different culture in how we approach
data science in general
and then we're going to finish with ning
who's going to go into a bit more detail
about how this business transition is
actually going to look like in practice
um so let me start by just setting the
scene a little bit for what I'm talking
about
um Phil kind of allude to this already
um but Rush is obviously a really big
company and today we're not here talking
for the whole of Rush all of us are from
a particular department at rush called
PD data Sciences
um if you don't know what that is that's
that's fine I'll explain it a little bit
now our basic job is to report clinical
trials
the rush obviously conducts loads of
different clinical trials all over the
world to gather data on the
effectiveness of the different products
we create to help fight diseases and our
role in PD data Sciences is to make sure
all that data is gathered accurately
following the protocols we've set out
and to summarize it
um so that we have a good picture of how
these drugs work so as you might imagine
this is a really important job it's
really vital that we get this right that
we have the safety and efficacy data to
be accurate and that we can share it
with Regulators as soon as possible
because as the the more quickly we get
this data summarized and presented the
quicker we can get drugs to patients to
help them fight illnesses
so what's our goal then
um so fundamentally our goal in PD data
Sciences is to shift towards a language
agnostic framework and what I mean by
that is we're moving away from having
one solution for how we do our
programming for clinical trials we want
the ability to be flexible and move
towards the best language for solving
our problems and our expectation is that
in future there won't be necessarily one
solution for for solving it we'll be
picking the best problem from the
marketplace
so most of what we're talking about
today is the first step on this journey
but we will be alluding to the kind of
The Wider ideas of this as well and that
first step I think has already been
mentioned a bit in the advertising for
this seminar which is that this year
um uh from Quarter Two novel studies
we'll be using r as their core data
science tool there will be analyzing our
data using R primarily
I will say that this is definitely novel
studies like we're not we're not doing a
cliff said thing where we switch
everything to R overnight
um because but it is a big change and we
expect that over the next few years
we'll have more and more studies using
our core data science tool until we're
using it as our primary tool across all
of our studies
um and this as I say is the first step
in this journey where in future we can
move flexibly in the future so R isn't
our destination it's part of a journey
that allows us to move towards what the
best data science tool is in the future
um so just a bit of context setting for
this if you're not super familiar with
Pharma
um farmer in general
um has typically used commercial
software to support filings um I think
that's been true across the industry and
it's been true for a really long time
that's kind of the way we've been doing
things um and there's lots of historical
reasons I won't get into there but it
does mean that our talent and tools are
at least historically really reflected
this you know we have a code base that's
being built up over 20 30 years and a
talent base that's been using that code
base for this time so that's kind of
just a highlight why this shift is big
for us
um so why are we doing this
um there's loads of different reasons
that have inspired us to make this
change I'm going to highlight a few
today but I wouldn't say that this is an
exhaustive list
um when it comes to R in particular R is
something that had been used at rush for
a while but I would say the kind of
wedge product that got it used a lot
more at PD data Sciences in particular
was our shiny our shiny really offered
capabilities we didn't have already in
the tools we had the ability to make
these interactive apps using Code so so
quickly and simply really proved a
really attractive offer and really
encouraged us to start using our at
least behind the scenes in clinical
studies and in fact one of the earliest
our packages that was built in-house to
support this was a package called teal
which Thomas is going to talk about
about later that this is now open source
you can follow that URL to go to to see
that package right now and this was an
in-house solution for standardized
Channel apps
so we had this kind of uh justification
for why we wanted to start using our
more and then there were a few other
things that really started to weigh off
towards thinking about moving towards R
um one was just about uh the talent base
generally speaking when we're recruiting
new graduates they're much more likely
to know these open source tools such as
r or indeed python than they are
commercial software
um but the final point which I think is
um a bit more future looking is we
wanted to go open the source and the
reason for this is we think open source
offers loads of opportunities for how we
work
um the first is just around getting
latest developments more rapidly
typically if there's a new statistical
method used to analyze data that will
often be implemented in r first of all
so if we want to get access to those
more quickly to provide better results
then we should be using our
the other is we knew we wanted to go
language agnostic we knew we wanted that
ability to switch between languages and
we know that open source is going to
make that easier because with no
proprietary format it's usually easier
to switch between contacts and the
obvious example of this is the ability
to switch between R and python there's
been a lot of effort to make those two
languages talk to each other nicely
and the last one which is one I'm really
excited about and Thomas is going to
talk about a bit more in a minute is the
ability to collaborate with external
Partners so up until you know a few
years ago all of our code was created
entirely in-house it wasn't really
possible for us to work with people from
outside of Russia but if we go open the
source we suddenly have this ability to
get the inputs of people from across the
industry which I think is in the long
run going to lead to much more efficient
and better code and ultimately better
outcome fast and for our patients
so hopefully that's been a good
introduction as to why we're doing what
we're doing and now I'm going to pass
over to Thomas he's going to talk a bit
about uh the as I say the environment
and the tools we're using in that
environment
thank you so much Karen
so then let's talk about the building
blocks of this kind of modern data
science platform we set out to create
which is really focused on open source
as its backbone
so first of all I would just like to
quickly dive a bit more detail into the
requirements we MPD data scientists have
for our day-to-day work and generally we
can separate our task into either the
regulatory side of things or the
exploratory side of things
and on the regulatory side of things
there's really four main deliverables we
need to create the first one is called
sdtm so sctm is an industry standard for
the data we collect the clinical trials
so regardless of how the data is
collected in the end when you submit it
to the health authority it has to be in
this data um standard such that it's
harmonized across companies
next up we have the analysis or atom
data sets and here you take the sctm
data sets as source and then you
transform them in a way that suits your
analysis Downstream so as a quick
example imagine you collect a
questionnaire which has 10 questions and
an overall summary score so the 10
questions you would have in your satn
data because that's the raw data as
collected but then you would calculate
the summary overall score as part of
your atom transformation
next up we need to perform a bunch of
statistical analyzes and that can be
something as simple and descriptive as
counting Adverse Events or something
much more complex for example fitting a
survival model or fitting a mixed
measures repeat model
and finally we need to put those
statistical analysis into an easily
digestible format and that's generally
either tables listings or graphs
and all these four components combined
make up the packages that we submit to
health authorities such as the US FDA in
order to get Market approval for novel
Therapeutics we are working on so this
is really at the core of our business
but of course we also have the
exploratory set of things and here
really it's highly context context
dependent what we need to perform and
therefore we need flexible tools and
really the best tool for the job so
having an open source background where
you have access to multiple languages
for example is really a good thing in
this context
we also need to consider that there's
novel data modalities
um we're getting more and more for
example Imaging data is becoming rapidly
and more on our trials digital biomarker
oh mix data Etc so it's not just the
classical rectangular data anymore which
we use to analyze in our commercial
software
and finally
um we want not only to enable our data
scientists to easily explore our data
but also people who don't work in data
science our colleagues in safety or
clinical scientists and we want to
really enable them to easily explore
their data and do so in a reproducible
manner such that they don't always have
to come back to us as data science and
we have this long feedback loop
and really all of this combined
necessity that we created a Next
Generation statistical Computing
platform where we could really perform
all these analyzes
and this is where ocean comes into play
our one Central analytics environment
which is the home for both our
exploratory and Regulatory work
so ocean is built in the cloud on AWS
and it's a language agnostic platform
which right now supports our python as
well as SAS for our Legacy work but it
is easily extendable because it's based
on Docker containers so if you spin up a
container with for example Julia in it
suddenly you would have access to that
language as well
for Version Control we are using git and
gitlab and we're not only using that for
our packages we develop internally but
it's actually will be there to store the
code for all our studies so if on a
study you program a particular atom data
set or an adverse event table the code
for that will be stored on gitlab
next up and this is really a big change
even though it sounds somewhat silly but
we moved away from this proprietary
format set 7B that that used to be
um the only format really that we used
to store our serious data and instead we
opted for an open source format called
parquet which is developed by the Apache
foundation and it's a binary format for
handling rectangular data and it's
highly efficient in both reading and
writing and it has Surplus already very
well so far
we have an internal rstudio connect
server as part of this platform where we
house our exploratory shiny apps and we
have a validated our package repository
so while typically you would install
packages from cran internally we use
this validated package repository and
you would find a lot of packages that
you know from cran such as ggplot2 or D
player over there as well as well as our
own open source packages we develop plus
internal packages and it goes through
and our own internal really streamlined
and efficient validation process which
is called Auto validate
then we are using another open source
tool called snake mate to orchestrate
our production runs and snake make is
very clever in a way because it creates
a directed acyclical graph of all the
artifacts that you need to create so
think of your sctms your atoms your tlgs
and then it really paralyzes as much as
possible taking dependencies into
account so what used to take maybe a
whole day for example to run everything
for a final clinical study report now is
done in a matter of hours if not minutes
and finally ocean is the tool as the
home of our next-gen tools for clinical
reporting and I will spend the rest of
my part talking about these next-gen
tools
so the first one of those is called Oak
and Oak is our solution for automating
sdcm mapping so sctm mapping used to
take a considerable amount of our time
and it was a rather labor intensive
process that was also somewhat mundane
so we really opted to streamline this by
creating an automation solution and
driven by metadata and our global data
standards at Roche Oak can now automate
around 80 of sctm domains with around 22
reusable mapping algorithms and this in
turn then really saved us a lot of time
we've seen already efficiency gains by
at least 50 percent so this is really
huge
and finally it's actually a fairly
simple tool to use because it's at the
end of the day a single r package you
interact with plus a web app but that
being said under the hood it's somewhat
more complex because it has to interact
with several systems and that's actually
why it's called the Oak Garden
and the first component of this Garden
is called pistol and honeybee
so really what you have to think about
is we have a metadata repository at
Roche which is the graph database and
inside that we store the mappings from
the raw data as we collected to this
sctm standard in a machine readable
format and that's really key here
because that makes it then easy for are
for example to query this information
and make use of it
next up we have our sctm spec Creator
which is called mint so this is a web
application in react to create the study
specific sctm mappings and when I say
that
um really most of it at least 80 percent
from what I had on the previous slide
should already be automated there if you
adhere to standards and then in this app
you have additional leader functionality
to add any non-standard mappings if for
example you connect somewhat a new data
endpoints which are not yet in our
standards
all of this is then saved in a
repository which is called saffron and
again in a machine readable format and
in the Json such a definitely queried
down the road in R and very importantly
any non-standards you would Define in
the mid application you would save in
saffron
such that you that you can reuse these
non-standard mappings across different
studies
and finally we have the actual data
transformation engine which is called
Oak and this is the r package people in
the end would use and really it's a very
streamlined process you fetched all this
metadata from saffron basically and then
you have a single function called per
satm domain and given all this metadata
it will then output your sdgm data sets
so the Oak Garden is not open source and
the reason for that being is that it's
fairly tailored towards our internal
Roche architecture but that being said
the overall principle is really broadly
applicable to anyone who has to map sdtn
data sets which is also the reason why
we're in active talks with the cdisk
open source Alliance to create a proof
of concept in which we would use C Dash
rather than our own internal data
collection standard as a source and if
that's something you and your
organization are interested in to
collaborate potentially then please
reach out I certainly have heard a lot
of questions regarding sctm and R at
iron farmer and so this might be a good
opportunity to reach out and maybe a
good collaboration can speak in all of
that
so we covered the first pillar of our
regulatory reporting site and now it's
time for the second which is the atom
data sets and here our solution is
called Admiral which is an open source
modular toolkit for Adam dataset
Creation in r and what is really unique
about Admiral is that unlike other
packages we developed and which are now
open source this did not start out as a
closed Source internal project and then
later on got open sourced really from
the start of it we collaborated with
another organization namely GSK
um to hit the ground running and build
something that would be usable not only
for Rush purposes but really for the
industry as a whole and I think it's
fair to say that this has been quite a
success we certainly want to use this
kind of model of collaboration going
forward and and when I say success I
think one metric that really hits that
home is that what started out as this
collaboration between two organizations
to create one r package now is actually
an ecosystem of our packages which are
developed by seven pharmaceutical
organizations in total
so in addition to Admiral we now have
Admiral uncle where Amgen and Bristol
mile script joined us with their
oncology expertise
there is the Admiral opta package which
nobody's um and rosh are working all
together and finally GSK is
collaborating with Pfizer and Jonathan
Johnson on this Admiral vaccines package
and if you and your organization are
interested in leveraging R and Adam and
Admiral for adding data set
transformation and you have expertise in
a particular therapeutic area again
please reach out
um we would really love to see this
ecosystem growing
next up I want to talk about our
statistical engineering team which is
really working at this intersection of
biostatistics and statistical or
software engineering actually
so this team really focuses on
accelerating the adoption of Novel
statistical methods so really all the
cutting-edge stuff that comes out of
Academia and trying to implement that as
software
and so far this has been mainly focused
on our packages
um and also occasionally Stan or C plus
plus have been used in the background
but the team is really open also to
other languages for example Julia
basically anything that is open source
and a viable solution for statistical
computing
and really important to highlight is
this this team is not only working at
Roche alone but it's part of a larger
industry-wide effort namely the software
engineer working group of the American
statistical Association where not only
rush and other pharmaceutical companies
but also academic institutions jointly
work together to basically Implement The
Cutting Edge of Statistics in software
and here's just a couple of examples of
packages the statistical engineering
team has worked on the mrmm package down
there is actually the first one that
came out of this software engineering
working group and another one I would
like to highlight is this RBM I package
for reference based model amputation
which won an award by the Royal
statistical Society last year once again
this has been a collaborative effort in
this case between Roche and the
University of bath so an academic
Institution
so finally on the regulatory side of
things we have the creation of our
tables listings and graphs and really
when we started doing that in R the G
part the graph part was the easy one we
just used gtplot2 it was the best tool
available for the job it still is in our
opinion
um and it was certainly also a big
reason um why to shift to R in the first
place having such a good tool readily
available however the T side of things
the tables especially if you look a
couple years back and there was not such
a really good solution out there so what
we did is we created our own which is
called our tables
and our tables really has an expressive
and modern API for table generation and
R and very importantly it is built from
the ground up with the needs of clinical
reporting in mind and we think that this
is really key because the kinds of
tables you do in this space tend to be
much more hierarchical and complex than
say a typical table you would find in an
academic journal or even on some
websites
right now our table supports outputting
tables in plain text word PowerPoint PDF
HTML and the version on GitHub the
development version right now also added
RTF support
and this is an open source package which
you can install from either GitHub or
cred
something that is working in tenant with
our tables is turn and it's really a
complement that focuses around the
summary statistics because you can think
of it as bridging um the statistical
analysis you perform for example with
one of the packages we've seen on the
previous slide and then actually getting
them to display in the table
and this is yet again an open source
package which is readily available for
you also to use and check out
the the final piece on that kind of tlg
side of things is Chevron and this is
really about streamlining our processes
even further so when we started out
doing tables in R we had an internal tlg
catalog which looked something like this
so this is a particular event table and
you can see it's just kind of a code
dump you would copy paste
um into your study folder and then use
but really copy pasting is not a good
solution so we opted for something uh
sort of template based and right now you
can basically create the same table by
using the Chevron run function
indicating the template you want to use
and then feeding in your data and off
you go so further a further gain and
efficiency in that way
so finally let's talk also about the
exploratory side of things
um so I mentioned in the beginning we
want to enable our non-data scientist
colleagues to also easily and
importantly reproducibly analyze their
clinical trial data
so we set out
um on this journey and said that our
Chinese would be really a good solution
for that however we did have a problem
which is how do we actually get our 600
or so data scientists who are not shiny
developers to build these exploratory
apps in the first place
we did not want to train all of these
600 people to become a sort of shiny
gurus instead what we opted for is to
create this framework called teal which
Kieran already mentioned in the
beginning and this framework really
centers around reusable modules and it
really abstracts away a lot of the
complexities of building shiny apps from
scratch you don't actually have to care
so much about the UI as well as the
server logic in the modules you would
readily adopt from a catalog
this is an example of a very simple app
created using teal and you can see on
the top you have all these tabs and each
of the steps represents a particular
module so in this case it's a
demographic table module and what all
measures have in common is that in the
center you have a display in this case
it's a table but it could also be a plot
and then on the left in addition you
have this encoding panel where you can
kind of customize what you see in this
table for example here you could select
different variables to be displayed so
that's all the module specific part and
as I said we have a large catalog I
think even over 100 modules readily
available for our internal people and
also for you because this is open source
to use
but then the teal framework itself also
provides a couple of goodies that work
across all modules the first one of
which is this filter panel you see here
on the right so depending on which data
is used in a particular module it would
list out a data set on top and then you
have the ability to select any variable
out of these data sets to drill down the
data so in this case we have a
particular subgroup based up on ADSL but
if you imagine this would be some kind
of adverse event analysis you could
easily filter down for let's say serious
Adverse Events
next up you have this reporter
functionality and this is a really neat
one anything that you create in any of
these modules you can add to a shopping
basket sort of and then at the end of
the day you can go to the card and check
out by exporting a PDF report or a
PowerPoint report and which would then
contain everything that you added to the
card so maybe a demographic table a
couple of Mile plot a response table
whatever you may wish
and finally we have this show R code
button functionality and this is really
key for us because that enables the
reproducible nature of teal because
unlike Tableau for example or Spotfire
which are also great tools to visualize
data and drill down and this is really a
hundred percent reproducible because if
you click the button you will get a
complete R script including loading all
packages loading all data that is needed
filtering the data as you have in the
filter panel here and then reproducing
the exact display that you see here
and that's really we think um a key for
us
so I already mentioned this has been
open source since last year and the code
is available on GitHub for you to look
at and also to install it from there
we have two sample apps which are
publicly available and the previous
picture I showed is one of those so
definitely check those out
and actually teal has been used in an R
submission pilot to the FDA which is
quite an exciting development kind of
instead of the static tlg submitting a
shiny app and there will be more
communication about that in the future
we have an upcoming webinar around teal
at the end of February where we will
dive deep into this particular tool for
an hour or so
and finally we are looking for
collaborators to develop this framework
further and I think that really goes to
all the tools that we've shown here kind
of in the spirit of the open source
Community where we take a lot of the
great stuff that other peoples have put
out there we also want to put the
packages we develop out there and
collaborate with others to develop them
further
and finally I would just like to mention
that this everything sort of I said is
part of this larger effort in the
industry called the farmers where
different pharmaceutical companies come
together and develop our packages for
end-to-end clinical reporting that's
really a great development which we
really hope and further gains traction
this year and the years to come and with
that being said here and I hand it back
to you
foreign
so yeah um Thomas has spent some time
um talking about
um the sort of setup of how we're going
to do our rush so we've kind of uh it's
not all finished with very close to
finish you know it's a work in progress
where we have this environment we're
going to work and we have this tool base
and certainly both of those are going to
continuously evolve over time but we
have a good idea of what we're doing
there and we've prevented that now
um but the other piece that we really
can't forget about when it comes to
moving to a new language is looking at
our talent base making sure that they're
ready for this change and it definitely
is a big change you know it's not just
about shifting to R we're changing the
environment we're working in we're
changing the tools we're using
conversion control so there's a lot of
things for our talent to learn and we
need to make sure that they're supported
so what I'm going to talk about for the
next 10 minutes or so is just about some
of the measures we're taking to support
everyone and this is all you know this
is a work in progress this is something
we're learning with as we're going and
certainly I expect to be giving uh
future talks in a year's time where we
talk about what worked and what doesn't
but here's at least some of our ideas
that we're kind of throwing out there
right now
so just thinking for a second about who
we have working in PD data Sciences
there's a real mix of uh different
people here we have people who've been
in the industry for 20 or 30 years and
have never coded an r at all so they
have a wealth of experience in clinical
trials but they don't have much
experience in r in particular or get as
well and then we have uh people who are
our experts and we've got a lot of
people who've joined the company more
recently who um as I kind of alluded to
earlier have this our experience and
haven't had the opportunity to apply it
in in the context of clinical report
now the other challenge we have is that
not everyone's transitioning to r at the
same time so again this is something I
mentioned in the intro that um we're not
you know we're not moving every single
person to our uh all at once we're doing
it in a phased way and that's good from
a management point of view but it does
mean that you can't just give everyone
training one day and expect them to be
able to apply it the next day and the
other thing
um that I think is really important when
it when you think about transitioning to
a new language it's not about just
learning kind of how to use that
language it's also about being fluent in
that language
um we really want our programmers to
start being able to know what good our
code looks like not just be able to
throw something together that just about
works
[Music]
so as I say I'm going to go through some
of the solutions we've looked at
um for dealing with these issues
um so the big one I think is around
helping guide our users
so because of all those challenges we
have doing active live training isn't
always going to be possible
realistically in terms of resource
restraints and the fact that everyone's
not transitioning at once it doesn't
make sense to do live training certainly
something will do but we need people to
be able to do self-study and the problem
with self-study is that if you just get
put someone in a room and tell them to
learn a subject they might be able to do
it but it's going to be challenging
they're not going to know where to start
necessarily and in particular that you
know they might go on a journey that
helps them a bit but isn't as guided as
it should be so we've been looking at a
few different ways to make this more
effective
the first idea is um to work out what
people don't know
um often when we've been sending out
initial surveys on people's knowledge on
subjects we do in a kind of granular way
we say you know how long have you been
programming this language how good do
you think you're on it and
self-assessment on that level can be
helpful but it's often true particularly
when you're starting a subject that you
kind of you don't know what you don't
know so you you there may be gaps in
your knowledge and you're just not aware
of them because you're not familiar
enough with the language and certainly
uh for those of you who are familiar
with r there's lots of pitfalls when it
comes to the complexity of how R works
that if you've only starting off with r
you're not going to necessarily know
about so that's what the data science
profile does it breaks all of these
categories into discrete topics and then
Builds assertions on kind of knowledge
we'd expect people to know to be
considered proficient in that topic so
I've got a screenshot which is an
example here forget and it's got a
collection of different things I might
expect as basic knowledge when you're
starting in get and basically this is
all based on self-assessment so it's not
we're not trying to catch people out
here we're not trying to trap anyone we
want an honest uh reflection of where
they are and that helps them to
understand where they need to focus
their learning on
so the next step is
giving them the resources to um
fill those gaps that they have and one
important thing uh we've kind of thought
about if we don't really want to
reinvent the wheel what I mean by that
is there can be a Temptation when you've
got some time the ability to create
training materials to go ahead and just
start making training resources without
thinking maybe this resource exists
already there's a huge amount of
material online both free and available
via commercial license and some of it is
great
um the challenge that a new learner has
is they don't necessarily know how to
direct themselves in this
so we've already got a bit of a start
and they know the kind of topics they
want to work on but even then what are
the best resources for them to use and
what order should they be progressing
through them
so what we've built for this is an
in-house solution which we're calling
the data science university and what
this is is it's a tool to create
existing materials so what we do and
we've got an example here is we build
learning paths on a particular topic so
this is a good coding in our topic where
we pick out we pick that into discrete
topic so again that link to that data
science profile seeing where your gaps
are and in each one we provide material
that we think is of high quality for
learning about that subject and again
that may be an in-house training that
we've created but it could well be a
great resource that's available for free
online
um so that the other thing I wanted to
mention as well is obviously a couple of
these things are in-house and you may be
curious about some of the material we're
producing at rush well I wanted to take
a little opportunity to do a sneaky
advert for something that's coming out
very soon on Coursera we've actually
been building
um a genentec based course called making
data science work for clinical reporting
um this is actually going to be part of
a wider specialization and it's going to
look at how we think data science should
be done in the context of clinical
reporting so this course is literally
being beta tested this week so I'm
really hopeful that it's going to be out
either this month or early in February
so look out for that if you're
interested in the kind of material we're
producing around learning how to use
data science in the context of clinical
reporting
so when it comes to making uh training
resources
um one thing that I think is really key
um that's kind of been learned by hard
experience is try to make sure it's
relevant
um one experience we've had when we've
uh for instance paid for external
trainers to come here is that training
material might be really great
um but it doesn't take advantage of the
fact that we kind of know what we do for
a living right we know what our
programmers are doing in their
day-to-day work so when we develop
trainings we can make it relevant to
what they're actually doing
um so there's it definitely involves an
effort but I think you get a lot of
value by making problems real one simple
way of doing that is just picking out
real data um not using empty cars or
Iris which is what you'll find on online
resources
um and that's what we've done in the
trainings we've built in-house
um there's actually an open source
package that we've created
um specifically for generating
synthetics Edith's data um so you can
make use of that right now that's the
the link on the screen there
and so the last point on training is
making sure it's at the point of need so
this is kind of relating to what I was
saying early on that not everyone is
moving towards using our um all at once
so we're doing our best to focus our
training on those who need it we're
training in cohorts rather than trying
to train everyone at once because if you
take a training a year before you
actually apply it you've basically
wasted your time because you've
forgotten everything you're using in
that time period so our goal is training
at the point of need
the last point I want to make which is
going to lead into ning talking about
the business transition is that while
I've talked a lot about training here
learning really isn't about training
um so that relates to that last Point
realistically how you learn is by
applying all of those trainings in your
actual day-to-day work
so we want to encourage that kind of
context learning so um and as well as
that we also want to build this culture
where you are always looking to improve
how you code so this is speaking back to
this idea of not just making people
learn a language but also becoming
fluent in that and there's a few
different things we're focusing on to
try and support that
um one is about building good Frameworks
to apply knowledge so in this
environment we're building up making
sure we have good Frameworks where we
encourage people to follow best practice
just by those Frameworks the other is
around learning via code review and
seeing other people's code certainly one
of the ways I became a much better R
programmer was by reading code written
by someone who is a better programmer
than me and you know I had I had code
that worked but when I reviewed their
code I realized that I could be doing
things much more efficiently and writing
code that's much clearer to read and
easier to use in the future so we're
really going to encourage this culture
of code review of looking at code and
seeing how how we can do better
um on one connected idea with that which
was actually inspired by the uh tidy
birthdays run by posit was having these
internal hack events which we called
hack R
um where we basically took all of those
um tools we're building that Thomas went
through and highlighted issues that we
thought people could take on so we said
to our wider data science audience get
involved dot you can improve these tools
and this is another way of highlighting
this idea of an open source culture the
idea that these tools that we're using
and developing to do our work they're
not some kind of you know they're not
made by Wizards in this guy they're
something we can work on and improve and
we can collaborate together to lead to
better code for all of us
so the last thing which is connected to
that is um learning as teams so I
mentioned that we're not transitioning
it once so when we're bringing teams as
a whole into this new environment and
we're going to make sure that they learn
together because they think another way
of um learning quickly is by learning
with peers so we're going to make sure
that teams up skilled together
um we're going to support uh people on
their Journey with additional mentoring
where we share Knowledge from Individual
to individual as well
so
um I'm going to pass now to ning who's
going to talk a bit about how with that
transition for those teams is going to
work
thank you very much Kieran yeah so I'll
take over and talk about how we make how
we are making our business transition
yeah so as Thomas already eluded a
little bit like from Rose we're a huge
company within roach data Sciences we
have over a thousand employees and we
are working on over 200 active molecules
so as you can imagine we have a really
diverse group over there with different
skills at a different background and
also we have very diverse type of
projects
and in addition to that also as you may
already get a feeling from Thomas Thomas
presentation that like uh for this
transition the scale is very large not
only because we have a larger team but
also because uh there are so many new
tools available out there including the
the our packages as well as some some
are noun are tools including git Docker
cloud computing and sname make this is
the beauty of Open Source but also you
can imagine that that introduce
additional complication to our to our
business transition
so to ensure a successful business
transition we realize that we really
need to make sure that we can Empower
every single project team to make their
own decision and also to make their own
FIFA purpose transition plan we're kind
of thinking that for each project team
when they try to modernize their data
science tools it's sort of like
renovating their house so as we all know
that our families decide to renovate
their house each family has their own
own needs some families may spend more
time on renovating kitchen and bathroom
and maybe other families will spend more
times on renovating living rooms and for
people who are purchasing a new house
they probably will pick out the new
Tools in new materials when when
modeling remodeling their house
similarly for analytical projects we're
thinking that learning this transition
Journey for some of the analytical
project teams maybe they they think that
it's valuable to refactor everything
including data process data analysis
Etc and maybe for other teams like their
data pipeline data data processing
pipeline is very stable using the
existing tools and they prefer to keep
using the existing tools for data
processing but only adopt the new tools
for data analysis and for brand new
projects we think probably likely the
the project team would love to start
from the newer tools so we want to
enable each project team to make a plan
that are tailored to their needs in
addition to that similar to remodeling
each family probably have a different uh
different like best timing for their
remodeling so for analytical project we
also think that different teams should
have the flexibility to pick up a good
timing for their team to adopt this
transition uh likely that that will be
the time frame when they don't have too
many business critical deliverables and
lastly of course different analytical
teams have different access to Thailand
pool and resources
although we want to we want to empower
each individual team to make their own
decision as a big organization you can
imagine that like it's probably you will
probably create a lot of chaos if we
just go think push things in a
decentralized way and ask everybody to
make their own decisions so as an
organization we still need to want to
have some light coordinations across
different teams so at the end of the day
we really want to come up with the
adoption roadmap for the next couple of
months uh with that we will have an
under holistic understanding about how
many teams are planning to be onboarded
in in certain time frame and what are
their needs what are the tools they need
to learn Etc
in addition to that by having such an
adoption roadmap we also think this is a
very good opportunity for us to build
some mechanism to enable iterative
feedback to our to developer team we're
hoping that for each wave of onboarding
we there will be a mechanism to feedback
to the to development team so that we
can keep improving our tools as the
outboarding goals
so how can we achieve that how can we
can come up with such adoption plan so
from Roche we have a small group of
people coming together created this
adapter scheduling team and we work
together with the project teams trying
to trying to work out this adoption plan
so like the project teams will still be
the final decision maker but we have
this scheduling team over there trying
to coordinate the onboarding timing
across different teams and also trying
to provide consultations to them for
them to understand the truth
availability
Etc
so what are some of the considerations
when we build up our our adoption
roadmap
the first thing is definitely business
continuity we want to make sure that
that for each project team they can
identify a couple of good transition
timing for themselves and then we can
stay stick with those good good timings
so that we have many we can minimize
business Interruption when doing this
transition
secondly we also want to take this
opportunity to enable early
collaboration between the developers and
also the users and to allow iterative
development therefore we decided to
start our adoption at a very early stage
even before other tools are 100 ready so
we engaged a small number of users when
the the tools are still somewhat Half
Baked and then we ask for feedback and
we also encourage the users to actually
co-create with us by filing bugs or or
by even contributing code back to back
to the code base
the other thing we noticed from past
experience is that if we look for early
testers uh our early tester volunteers
sometimes we are getting those like
expert users being very active to beat
early testers but those users may not
represent the majority of the user base
therefore when planning out this
adoption roadmap we reach out
proactively to different teams and try
to try to include a diverse type of
projects and user base in each wave to
represent our user base
in addition to that we also want to make
sure that when we work out this roadmap
we we want to ensure that the trainer
and support capacity are considered we
don't want to overload our trainer or
the support team in a short a short time
frame and we want to make sure all the
users get sufficient support
and lastly uh and lastly in the
discussion between the scheduling team
and also the project team team the
schedule team the secondary team also
provide consultations to help the uh to
help the the project teams to identify
relevant tools and processes to be
adopted and as mentioned not every
single study need to adopt other tools
out there and also and also as mentioned
like like uh for early adopters not all
the tools are ready already when teams
start to start to onboarding so this so
our scheduling team also make sure that
project teams adoption timeline allies
with our tool availability
foreign
so to support this journey as you can
imagine this is not something that can
be driven by a small group of people
although it is a Thomas and Kieran
myself presenting here uh today uh there
were there is really a large community
behind who is driving this transition
within rosh and also in the Pharma
industry and we really want to say thank
you to everybody who got involved and I
also want to mention that for many
people who are driving those activities
they are not spending 100 of their time
on developing a software or spending 100
of their time on the change management
part rather majority of people are still
working on molecule teams and they're
spending 20 to 30 percent of their time
out driving certain aspects of of our
transition here
so what are some of the communities that
are driving this transition within Roche
the first one is definitely the software
product teams those are the developers
who wrote our packages who built the
infrastructures who wrote their business
tools
we also have a ways of working community
and those are the people who are looking
at how we can integrate the new tools
with existing business processes and
they can they also come up with new
guidelines in terms of like ways of
working using newer tools
and there is this romance room aspect
scheduling Community a group of people
who interview with the project teams and
provide consultation to the project
teams to come come up with a adoption
roadmap
and when it comes to come closer to our
project teams on boarding timeline they
will be assigned with a onboarding coach
in the onboarding coach will help them
to identify certain training materials
that are relevant to their team also
Point them to to activities such as
hackathons Kira mentioned
and there is a user support Community
answering the questions from the users
and lastly there is a communication
Community who share our who share our
adoption progress to The Wider community
and also share with people what to
expect as a Next Step
so where are we right now uh learning Q3
to Q4 last year we welcome a couple of
teams joining us as early adopters we
had two waves two waves of early
adopters join us and as mentioned for
those early adopters they when they join
us our systems our tools are not 100
ready yet and they're really the
Trailblazers helping us to test out the
tools and have like early interventions
giving feedbacks Etc and for those two
for those project teams they did have
some backup Plans by using the existing
tools because the newer tools and
systems are not 100 ready yet
so in Q2 and Q3 this year we will
welcome a couple of new molecule teams
joining us so for those new molecule
teams they are the teams who doesn't
have and they who don't have any Legacy
code so they will start everything from
scratch so as you can imagine they will
they will be using the new Tools
end-to-end in end-to-end fashion uh and
then and then they were kind of like uh
they will build this like whole like
end-to-end process using our newer tools
and we're really excited to see that how
that how that testing goes and after
that if everything goes smoothly in
queue four we expect to welcome more
studies more project teams joining us
for writer robot in that rollout we will
welcome some of the new studies and also
will welcome some other projects who
already have some existing code and they
will pick the part that they might
decide to to refactor some of their code
or maybe they just decide to my way to
the new system without refactoring their
code
so the journey continues and we're
really really excited to be part of this
journey and hopefully if we got a chance
to speak again in a year or so we can
share more good news
so with that I think we are happy to
take any questions
all right awesome thank you so much
Roche and Janine Tech Team lots of
wonderful information tons of questions
are coming in I know we've got about six
or seven minutes here so I'm just gonna
jump right in with a couple questions
that are floating to the top so the
first one I'm seeing is what hurdles did
you have to overcome for transitioning
from SAS 7B dad to parquet files for
data storage
foreign so
um yeah so this is an interesting one
because
um you know ning just mentioned you know
we'll come back in a year and we'll tell
you success stories so some of this is
you know this is work in progress these
are things we're trying out right now
and we haven't got too much experience
of doing it so this is our Our intention
and we you know we have some uh early
teams that are trying out storing in
parquet and so far that that's working
really well um there's obviously going
to be attention when you're doing things
in in parquet organ from beat up because
you've got to get sass to be able to
read that files but we're building
solutions for that to be able to happen
um but the I mean at least for natively
using them in R um we're quite
optimistic about it because parquet is a
really efficient format and just in our
testing it seems to be that it's going
to be a a really good format for
um not only for R but also when we if we
use python python can read parquet
natively as well yeah
fantastic any other comments on that one
maybe that's not related to this
particular question but somehow there
was a question I think around whether in
the end we still have to submit these
xpt files which is a SAS format to the
FDA and actually indeed that's the case
so this is something we use internally
for data storage and once the data makes
it to the FDA we'll use xbt or maybe if
the FDA approves this new format which
is being proposed data set Json
fantastic all right let's move on to
question two can you speak more about
the capabilities shiny offers that you
did not have
foreign
I think really one key aspect for us was
around this reproducibility
um I mentioned um because for example
Tableau or spot fire are stuff that we
used internally it's certainly very
powerful and you can do lots of stuff
but if a safety scientist has such a
dashboard and comes with you this is
something I want to have in my CSR you
have basically no idea what how they
reach to that conclusion which subgroup
is this that you see on this plot and
how did they film about Adverse Events
Etc so that really was um for us a big
push and also we wanted to have
something which is sort of which Bridges
this gap between the regulatory side of
things or kind of classical tables and
the exploratory nature so a demographic
table I showed you basically looks the
same in the app as it would in the final
CSR and thereby it's really a nice match
between those two
awesome any other comments on that one
or maybe just to add um so for example
I'm not sure how much statistical
analysis functionality Tableau or spot
Fire have they're mostly for visualizing
data but for example until you can fit
an mrmm model which is something fairly
complex and I'm not sure besides SAS and
R and which other languages even can do
that and certainly I don't think any
dashboard
um app out there has the capability
right right awesome Let's uh move to
question three is there a balance of
using Python and R in your strategy or a
wholesale decision for R if the latter
how was that made
so I I think the way to look about it is
um uh the the backbone of our data
science is going to be our so our focus
of developing tools is going to be art
so when we look at our resource of our
actual teams building the tools that
we're going to use that's going to be
enough and that's kind of the natural
outstretch of that is that most teams
are going to be using are because that's
what the tools have been building but
there will be the ability to use Python
where the problem uh is more easily
solved in Python
um as to why are
um I I don't know what I don't know if I
want to say anything too controversial
about the differences between harm and
python but I think it's fair to say that
as a statistical piece of software uh in
the open source um I would argue that it
is at least equivalent with python when
it comes to statistical problems
um and there's a lot of benefits in
terms of just like what our talent based
knew already
um yeah I don't know if anyone else
wanted to say anything else so much
yeah I totally agree I feel like right
now probably Academia versus so are the
ones that his own methodology is like
many of them are still developing are in
the yeah for example mmrm Etc yeah so so
I think like right now there's more
tools available or for some of the
sexism methods yeah
got it
all right gonna move to a popular
question that comes up quite a bit what
kind of validation is required for using
R python for clinical trials reporting
um so yeah I think Thomas mentioned
already
um the auto validate tool
um but I should say that that come from
a history of of collaboration across the
industry
um so um there was uh still going the
the r validation Hub uh group
um which I think uh I think is still led
by Andy Nichols uh who it was initially
anyway
um which looked at these kind of
questions as to
um what you know is is our validated how
do you validate and our package and
those kind of questions from it
um so it was kind of a collaboration
um taking these sort of outcomes from
that and building those into our
internal Solutions working with our
internal validation teams to get
consensus
um and yeah the auto valid AR was a a
real late forward
um for us because it was an in-house
solution for validating our packages
really quickly
um effectively automatically that's why
it's called to validate
um in that we have these standard
measures of an r package quality that we
can use to assess whether we think and
our package can be included and I mean
if it doesn't mean they're standard then
we have to do some action but if if we
get on our package and it meets all
those standards then it can be included
in our in our suite of packages kind of
straight away
um which is a real what's a real Leap
Forward for us
all right we're almost at the hour here
so we're going to go a little fast on
these next two but let's uh squeeze them
in if we can the next one is how much
manual work do you have with this
approach between raw data and stdm and
atom
okay
so the piece from raw data to sttm as I
mentioned we are getting around 80 or so
automated which means you only have to
take care of the manual 20 you would go
into this Mint app and then basically
say okay this is how I want to map this
raw data into this standard and if you
have done it for one study you can
actually then reuse it again for the
next thereby again gaining efficiency so
this should be really fairly streamlined
um then the next step from sctm to Adam
that's much more difficult because it's
not just a simple mapping depending on
the analysis you want to perform
Downstream you need to derive certain
things so while we have template code
available that implements sort of our
general standards that will always have
to be extensions and this will be a much
larger part of the work compared to sttm
all right anything else on that one
two more questions we'll knock out here
pretty quick all right question six here
do you keep the data sets under Version
Control and gitlab
Etc along the code if so do you have
these with large data files yeah but we
can just say no no we don't so we we
have a separate solution which I think
Thomas mentioned um using S3 for storing
our data
um yeah okay yeah I think it's fair to
say if we did start on GitHub on gitlab
yes we would have a lot of trouble
all right well the Roche ecosystem of
apps work with the form of verse Suite
or is it one ecosystem versus the other
it's an interesting way to put it so um
more or less everything I talked about
is actually part of the former verse and
the farmer verse is
um
you don't have to think about it as kind
of us putting it out there there's lots
of companies contributing various stuff
there's actually our tables for example
as part of it but there's other table
packages as well so it's just kind of a
curated list of packages that adhere to
a certain set of Standards
um and that are useful for clinical
reporting
um and most of them work independently
of each other so you can mix and match
whatever you want to use and I don't
really think there is like a rush kind
of App Suite kind of just the farmer
versus out there and we're using as much
as possible
um
I think we got uh one more question here
that was quite popular there one that
came in about parquet I think we got to
that one so I'm going to skip it but the
next one is can you please elaborate on
the auto validate for packages I think
there was some interest on that
okay
um so I I think
um yeah so the basic idea is um it's a
tool that can generate reports the kind
of standard reports we need for
validation so those are generated by by
the tool and what you do as a as a as a
user as a creator of an art package is
you submit your our package and you make
sure it meets a sufficient quality check
so we have a list of different quality
checks that it does I don't know if the
top of my head what they all are but
they include things like obviously
passing cram checks having uh test
coverage past a certain level
um you know all these kind of uh
sensible things that um we think denote
on our package being a sufficient
quality and if you pass those then Auto
validate does the rest of the work for
you
yeah
and that was a great talk by our
colleagues at on Farmer just on this
topic I think like 20 minutes so if
that's of interest to you definitely
check that out yeah and you can uh you
can get that talk and others on the RN
Pharma YouTube channel
um I think with that I'm gonna thank all
of you for such wonderful information I
know there's a lot of excitement about
the webinar Thomas that you mentioned
that's coming up I think they can get
that is that through the arc Consortium
webinar yes it is and it's not yet on
the website unfortunately okay but
February 24th it's the day teaser
exactly all right yep keep an eye out
for that and with uh with that I will
wrap it up thanks for all the great
questions and comments it's great to see
the community come out uh thanks again
for all the effort and time to put this
together especially right after the
holidays and with that I'll uh wish
everyone farewell and have a great day
morning evening where you are thanks a
lot